welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the illuminati and doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness is
confirmed to have a mystery seventh
member due to an open seat on that
illuminati dais that did not belong to
838 steven strange a 3 8 steven
sorcerer's supreme seat went to mordo
third from the left mordo replaced a 3 8
strange on that panel after the other
members of the illuminati executed
steven which then opened up that seat
for sorcerer's supreme morto and now
this has been confirmed by the movie
screenwriter who hinted that the open 7
seats occupant remained something of a
mystery to the 838 universe a mystery
that if you look at the comics that most
influenced the development of this
movie's illuminati sequence and by
looking ahead at marvel's narrative plan
we may be able to deduce who this seat
belongs to and why it is empty for this
trial and thanks to true bill for
sponsoring today's video more about them
later okay just to clarify again why
this open 7th seat does not belong to
838 steven strange the illuminati is an
assembly of representatives of the
various factions of superheroes it's not
a who's who of the most powerful or just
the groupings of superheroes and their
friends it is specifically leaders of
each faction we have one in only one
seat for sorcerers one seat for the
mutants one seat for the avengers one
seat for the inhumans one seat for
atlantis and one seat for the fantastic
war now initially in the comics t'challa
leader of wakanda was invited but ended
up turning them down and this scene in
multiverse of madness shows the 838
illuminati operates under the same rule
mordo introduces each member with the
body of superhero dome that they
represent baron carl mordo sorcerer
supreme sorcerer's check captain carter
the first avenger avengers check like a
garbolt gun inhuman king inhumans czech
maria rambo captain marvel defender of
the cosmos marvel cosmic czech reed
richards of the fantastic war fantastic
four check and professor charles xavier
mutants check it would not make sense
for a seven-member illuminati to have
two sorcerers on it furthermore mordo
was clearly not present with the
illuminati in that titan flashback as
they executed strange so mordo did not
join that panel until after the position
of sources of supreme opened up these
arguments that the illuminati might
leave the 7th seat open to honor 838
strange also don't really make sense
because they clearly stated they only
put up that statue outside as a public
display to mythologize that strange as a
martyr which was a lie that they clearly
feel guilty about in private they
actually still feel betrayed by their
friend so they definitely would not keep
an open seat in that room to honor him
in this private chamber now 838 strange
founded this group so it does make sense
that his seat would be at the center
where mordo now sits this empty seventh
seat is all the way at the end which
makes far more sense as the seat left
open for a rogue seventh member so when
still alive representing a different
faction of the 838 world someone they
hope might join them for a meeting
someday now screenwriter michael waldron
was asked about this open seat by the
hollywood reporter and he confirmed it
was something they talked a lot about he
made a joke about the set decorator
accidentally setting out too many chairs
and then when the interviewer was like
no seriously and followed up waldron
indicated that they do have an answer in
mind but wanted to leave it open-ended
for now and again if the answer was as
simple as well it was just 838 steven's
chair waldron would have said so clearly
there is another 838 hero out there
someone who they talked about someone
whom waldron considers it above his pay
grade to reveal so let's break down the
likeliest suspects if we go by the
illuminati in the comics we should start
with iron man tony stark you could look
at the ultron sentries of the baxter
foundation and conclude that there must
be a tony stark of this universe because
in 616 it was tony who created ultron
also back in iron man 2 616 tony had a
file on his phone labeled illuminati so
you could conclude from that that many
tonys across many universes would have
some illuminati-esque ambitions however
a38 is definitely a marvel elseworld and
in the age of ultron comics it was
actually hank pym who invented ultron
while these ultron sentries look just as
they do in age of ultron really the look
of ultron in the mcu is based on the
comics so either way it's just kind of
hard to use these centuries as evidence
of who created them if anything it seems
like reed richards and his team of
technicians were the source of the
technological innovations of this
reality waldron has confirmed in other
interviews that the rumors that tom
cruise might be playing a superior iron
man in this movie were not true cruz
never shot anything for this movie he
was never even approached but captain
carter's look is very similar to peggy
and what if and that peggy was given her
union jack shield by howard stark so
it's at least likely that some stark
family exists in 838 really the
arguments against tony being that
seventh member of the illuminati is that
his role has already been filled by
other members because in the comics tony
represents the avengers and he's the one
who formed the group but in 838 the
avengers seat is occupied by captain
carter and it was 838 steven strange who
formed the group now if you're hoping
for a multiversal version of yourself
that's better with money we'll jump
through a portal to help you sort your
finances out our friends at truebill are
here to help with a more realistic
solution truebill is an all-in-one
finance platform that helps you save
more and spend less through the app you
can track your expenses manage
subscriptions lower your bills and build
your savings all in one place i really
like how easy truebill makes it to
safely and securely identify recurring
charges and cancel unwanted
subscriptions with just a tap it's also
got some nice credit score monitoring
tools to give you a little nudge when
something unusual might be happening it
won't alert you if a multiversal version
of you is trying to steal your identity
but it will help with lots of other
stuff truebill can also help you create
a custom budget that automatically
monitors your spending by category such
as dining out or entertainment they'll
send you friendly notifications when
you've exceeded your budget and you can
even visualize your spin to earn ratio
in the app get started with true build
today by heading to truebuild.com new
rockstars or by clicking the link in the
video description that's truebuild.com
new rockstars so let's look at another
original illuminati member in the comics
neymar the submariner ruler of atlantis
actually at many points in this movie it
seemed like namor might pop up strange
in america pass through an ocean world
and then later a post-incursion reality
shows the sea flooding manhattan as if
part of that war might have involved the
neymar flooding the coastline the squid
monster they fight was actually
confirmed by merch to be named gargantos
who is a name or villain waldron was
actually asked by neymar by variety and
he said that neymar was someone they
talked about but that marvel has other
plans for him in the mcu maybe even the
same occupant of that seventh seat that
waldron and his team talked about so
what would marvel's plans for namor be
well there were some rumors last year
that marvel had cast narcos actor
tanakuerta as namor and black panther
wakanda forever but that was never
confirmed atlantis and wakanda do have a
pretty fierce rivalry in the comics and
that's a big reason why t'challa resists
joining the illuminati to begin with and
when i look at that seventh seat and
wonder well what faction the marvel
world is still left unrepresented i
would think one of their other
independent kingdoms of earth atlantis
or wakanda which brings me to the option
i think actually might be likeliest and
explain why the seat was left empty in
this movie t'challa the black panther
waltran confirmed in interviews that
when he drafted this version of the
illuminati he drew primarily on the
comics run by jonathan hinkman that i
mentioned in my last video 2013's new
avengers incursions event which opens
with t'challa witnessing a red alternate
earth in the sky over wakanda and then
begrudgingly reassembles the illuminati
t'challa is the point of view vocal
character that brings us into these
incursions and when we go into the
post-incursion reality of this movie
what do we see in the sky a giant red
planet therefore i think that seventh
seat might actually belong to the one
member of the illuminati historically
hesitant to join the six others but one
that they would always leave one seat
open for t'challa maybe even in this
movie they considered a masked variant
of t'challa but ultimately decided that
they didn't want to step on any toes of
black panther wakanda forever which is
still set to release later this year i
mean of course folks the options are
endless hank pym maybe 838 vision he'd
be an interesting option because we
confirmed that he is alive in this
reality but elizabeth olsen suggested he
is divorced from 838 wanda i would
suggest an asgardian or some other
extraterrestrial maybe 8384 838 valkyrie
838 jane foster thor but captain marvel
is there as a defender of the cosmos so
everything off world is uh covered maybe
838 kang but nathaniel richards
descendant of reed richards house of
richards is already represented here
truly i think the likeliest options are
one of the three likely options that we
saw in the pages of the comics this is
based on tony stark or namor or t'challa
each of whom have a reason to be on that
illuminati panel but each of them also
having their own set of complications
with revealing them ahead of upcoming
mcu titles so let me know who you think
is in that seventh seat except if you
still think it is 838 strange because
you are wrong you can support new
rockstars by checking out our merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter avos
following the rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you